bonsoir
ça va bien quand vous avez lu ce matin
j'imagine vous n'êtes pas de tomber des
nus vous êtes dit ça me rappelle
malheureusement des souvenirs
[Musique]
de 78 à 81 et l'initiation dans ce
temps-là que c'était ça fait couper les
cheveux
les choses que vous avez parlé dans
l'autobus j'ai pas vu ça puis on a fait
de Chicoutimi je continue l'équipe dans
le temps la plus éloignée au Québec puis
on voyageait beaucoup mais honnêtement
moi je pense que ça part d'en haut ça
part avec ta taille dirigeantes ton
propriétaire ton gérant général ton
coach je peux pas concevoir que
j'écoutais Martin que j'aspect
énormément que il y a un des coachs qui
est participé à
une situation de joie il y a participé
il y a même mais c'est même impliqué
c'est c'est incroyable c'est tu peux pas
permettre ça comme propriétaire parce
que dans le junior canadien ce sont des
propriét
c'est des jeunes qui arrivent à 15 ans
souvent puis ils vont aller jusqu'à 20
ans donc ce sont des jeunes adultes des
adolescents et puis c'est son son très
vert dans la vie il y a très et
on trace où on on se fit à ces gens-là
pour pour prendre soin de nos enfants
puis des choses comme ça arrivent mais
dans Martin dans le texte de Martin on
dit que il y a 19 témoignages de jeunes
qui ont joué dans 38 équipes donc ça
veut dire entre
2014 entre
entre 79 et 2014 sur 39 ans donc il y a
pas mal d'équipes qui avaient ce genre
de pratique là quand même
probablement écoute honnêtement moi dans
le junior j'ai continué avec le rapide
de Montréal j'ai convaincu ça non plus
mais comme vous dites
nous à Montréal quand je coachais le
rater de Montréal c'est Monsieur Savard
qui était propriétaire puis c'est chose
là n'était pas toléré et on était au
courant puis on laisse pas on ne sait
pas ça aller fait que c'est correct de
les cheveux des gars on le savait puis
on rencontrait les coachs ont rencontrés
les vétérans la journée que c'était pour
ce produit parce qu'on le sait on sait
ce qui se passe dans un club de hockey
tu rencontres ton capitaine des
assistants capitaines tu t'assure que ça
déborde pas il y a du plaisir mais
assurez-vous les gars mais je veux
savoir qu'est-ce qui s'est passé tu
parles aux joueurs qui ont été touchés
par ça comment ça a été ta soirée puis
si un problème tu voudrais puis je peux
pas croire c'est incroyable quand
j'entends qu'un coach participé à ça
avec des bâtons de hockey et puis c'est
vraiment moi je suis propriétaire d'un
club non mais juste avant était à
l'époque c'est sûr que je vais mettre
tous dehors puis écoute c'est
inconsolable est-ce que d'après vous
monsieur Delorme on doit encore rendre
plus sévère vous vous dites quand le
propriétaire est bien quand il y a des
bons coach en n'arrive pas parce qu'on
dit aux jeunes de faire attention puis
on met un cadre mais manifestement quand
le propriétaire
regarde d'ailleurs où se dit ouais ça
fait partie de la formation des jeunes
espèce de côté macho dérive machisme
est-ce que là on devrait faire des
règlements pour toute la ligue pour
serrer la vis
pourquoi pas la ministre tout à l'heure
qui disait que ces choses-là devrait
être interdit moi moi je peux vous dire
que ça fait couper les cheveux c'est pas
stupide
ça va arrêter là
tout le monde rit parce que c'est plus
grave parce que les jeunes ont tous les
jeux que les cheveux courts
c'est dans les années 70 on avait fait
un petit peu plus long mais ça c'est
correct mais moi je pense que ce serait
important justement la ministre qui en a
parlé ben rencontré des propriétaires
rencontrer les gérants généraux
rencontrer les coffres et puis il faut
limiter ces choses-là parce que c'est
pas assez aussi des choses si on parle
du hockey junior mais il y a aussi il y
a aussi le côté universitaire moi j'ai
entendu des histoires d'honneur avec
l'université Mégane à Montréal avec des
vols football
[Musique]
parce que c'est des choses qui c'est pas
la façon que tu es élevé en tout cas moi
la façon que j'étais élevé mes parents
c'est de voir ça mais je t'inviterai
pas correct sont des choses qui sont pas
que s'il y a des choses qui sont drôles
mais il y a des choses qui sont pas
verac ça c'est pas vrai exactement
d'autant que beaucoup de ces jeunes qui
sont qui sont plus jeunes maintenant qui
sont adultes qui sont marqués d'ici de
tout ça Gilbert Delorme ancien joueur
des Canadiens ancien coach et joueurs de
la ligue junior majeur du Québec merci
de nous avoir parlé très apprécié